when you lose inspiration or you lose
motivation how do you get it back I get
it back by remembering that you might
die tomorrow
so I'm inspired by practicality and
reality and the truth which is it is
ridiculously impossible to become a
human being I am one I have other good
things going for me as a human being and
I'm just grateful you're dwelling and
looking at what you don't have versus
looking at what you have if you actually
spent all your time looking at that
versus I don't have a million dollars
I'm not famous I don't have this if you
spend all your time on what you have
versus what you don't have you would be
the happiest girl on earth